Louie Anderson I'm very attracted to
Bryce Dallas Howard you live in here
have you have you met her through that
Oh shooty there's an energy in the room
Jim's gotten all Jim got all sexed up is
all sexed up I think I'd hug me
that's incredible on it slice up right
below is visa well Wow good to see you
buddy now you have to maintain that
energy for preneur em though that's
enough talking tonight yeah but you know
mm yeah you to do try to yeah what are
these some space there's a headshot yeah
they're a little difficult
yeah website is uh nevermind you got it
uh Houston welcome to the show man thank
you
how are you to the new show you guys but
yes yeah yes yeah not to open right now
and we did yeah you know it's time said
did you know we should have changed that
name but we tried to tell him try to
tell me oh listen no yeah no they died
so nice to be here nice to have you that
she seemed to have a tremendous amount
of charisma she really did just she get
she said hello in a way where you just
go yes hello yeah use it hi Ron Howard
daughter who I was looking at her face
and she's so beautiful in her hips like
you know she just yeah she has moving
arias yeah and he has that movie star
hip don't just uh she wasn't married Jim
you'd be right there you know this is
never stopped is it no but it's not Sam
yeah yeah I'm so [ __ ] delusional I
lift her up I was bummed out to find out
she was married
yeah she's 33 on 48 thank you if it
makes you feel like 33 goes into 48
hopefully if I connect yeah well I was
lettin you say that was a good softball
pitch Jim I'm glad you got it Jim if it
makes you feel better her marital status
makes no difference on whether or not
she would she would be with you I don't
know if that's true I thank you million
I think Joe's got a shot
I think Jimmy's always got a shot I
think you know certain people in life
want something real mm-hmm and Jimmy
real yeah it's the most real I don't
know if they want that
that's a real you know Novi was that
real that's very real well you know
eventually you're going to have to get
that yeah so this so if you dive into
that the better you could get to that if
people could get to that yeah in life
people are mostly just sitting around
they're not doing anything nothing
they're not working hard at what they
want to do they complain about
everything they don't really care about
what they're doing people I know I'm a
con I used to be the worst at that the
event did you do that
yeah at what point were you the worst
complainer yesterday yeah I was terrible
I had cleared it up this morning I you
to know that there's no complaints out
of me I'm just saying like I always had
one purpose though to be the greatest
you know stand-up comic ever so you wish
I had that purpose it wasn't enough to
be good you want to do your kind of
about it you know I would have a
competitive
I wasn't competing with any other comic
I can tell you that they were nothing to
me not in a bad way I loved them as
human beings but I I was trying to beat
myself out each time right because that
is where all the strength is I mean you
know I once worked on a joke for 12
years so boy jokes I used to do a joke
where my mom would drive me and my
brother nuts she'd come out we'd be
watching TV kids she'd stand right in
front of us kids what you're ruining our
lives you know when you're 12 you know
uh I'd even move my lips when I was 12
huh she goes what do you think I bought
what do you think I paid for that know
what she she's weirder like this what do
you think I got this outfit for you know
we have no idea how much that outfit
would cost
we don't know that would ten and twelve
right we don't know and I'd go 900 Louie
and then it would get a little titter it
was a joke that was I wanted to do
because it was setting up other things
sure never got much of a lot but I got a
laugh always yeah I go that's not to hit
joke that's not the punch line one time
twelve years later I keep working on it
it was October I go my mom comes in
front of us
what you think I got this outfit for
Halloween
Negreanu every under every good joke is
the is a better joke yeah don't you
agree well I know I find under every
good joke I tell is a is a bomb you may
go to a few but you have the perfect
yogurt I leave I leave a trail of holes
on the way to every decent joke
so Jimmy in the trailer hole what's the
worst I was when you shoot something and
then you try to stick the joke like when
you do a joke after you've already shot
it instead
and then you improve it a cop [ __ ] you
mean you shot it on paper so yeah see
look I can't do that joke anymore and
it's uh you realize that that's the
version you want it on tape yeah yeah
and what does it mean does it mean
anything in the big picture good good is
a really good thing
so does do if I have a great joke but
it's only necessarily better to me or
are you talking about a drug that isn't
as good you just find the joke that and
all of a sudden it works better after
like four summers you might find the
words like always better but does it
matter only do you write yeah probably
okay you know that nobody ever watches a
special goes you know except for that
seventeenth joke right yeah that's true
that coulda had a stronger punchy on or
later on the end of that I think we're
making it up as we're doing it did write
you know if you haven't killed me you
just stand up there and do that yeah
yeah I do
I'm a filament happy capture yeah that's
the one day and I was I was selling cars
yesterday hey they said we'd come in
here and shoot this I go yeah yeah
what's like well do are did do that Bob
Newhart like literally his he had the
top two comedy albums in the country the
top two albums and he had been doing
comedy less than a year that is one of
the most I love they write that was
around seven comics then right I'd
Louise write [ __ ] Bob no but you even
believe that story I should just wonder
I don't know you know cuz I go oh those
cows those cows those Elms were strong
don't you think while he was selling the
cars he was perfecting it with peach
birth and every buy the car but what do
you think of it yeah I'm a real low-key
all right pretend I'm a guy who's going
to take you on a driver's test isn't
that one of us do you think maybe he was
but maybe that's an urban legend that's
gone a little bit unchecked of course I
lie all the time about how I started
people have to realize these questions
like how'd you get started and I go oh
my god have you read anything done any
homework whatsoever so what do you tell
them what will you marry die here's my
good one lately because it's Millennials
now
yeah or pre Millennials what is the
Prima Lydia is that like right before
generation you know I got a lot out of
like just out of school or out of
college
oh so it's the new new whatever comes
after Malaysia Hawaii Liam yeah yeah
proposed my mistake a post posted by
that group oh yeah that's not a mistake
never post it was a mistake if she's
three good night everybody will be here
through the way so I'm tell them so
here's my new one well funny you should
ask
I do that because that's oh you know
that gives you a little more time when I
was I guess I might have been 12 or 13 I
can't remember and I was eating Cheerios
and the back I said you know what is
this be a stand-up comic so well is
crazy so luckily my parents would always
give me you know postage to them so I
filled the thing out be a stand-up comic
I want that I sent it in I got a little
book of jokes and I tried them out and I
go this is for me
and they go wow I know they has never
been printed right when they give it to
the editor uh he goes white for you more
you have to manually again specifically
write checks is another one I'll try to
get a night I love rice check please and
on the back of the rice yet because it's
more intellectual you know right you're
eating rice Chex
Martis yeah you're smarter it's a dick
Cavett's there and he's got a pencil
he's twirling it and I said oh and I
sent away and I was glib for two years
that's that that's the giveaway though
that's the editor go do you think he was
eating [ __ ] rice for breakfast that's
what you say that's what that's true
yeah yeah oh my god what is the way what
is the mindset of the post-millennial
have you encountered because I haven't
really people are really talking about
that yet are they people are so stuck on
the Millennials they are they're so mad
at them they're furio's you don't want
you know like hey listen I know that
you're in the middle of a thesis but
could I get my coffee did I just get you
know they're doing they could they look
right through you have you ever had that
yeah where they look I don't mind that
you're you don't care about anything but
don't get a job where I'm going to be in
contact with you right right you know
what I mean
don't make me feel the the ramifications
if you not care don't work in the
service industry don't work in this area
with your waters I'm saying I talk ISM
in the garage this fall on ffff egg by
the way congratulations thank you thank
you I'm [ __ ] amazing it is amazing
the nicest treat in the world to you
know just I you know I had I was sitting
there at the Emmys and you're talking
about the ending of course yeah you know
the whole thing
yeah whole success this whole amazing
role but the Emmys just of course sit in
there and you know Jimmy Kimmel one of
my favorite people's hosts in it and
just so funny and sweet and the games on
so I know it you know sales there for me
cousin sale and so it's the Vikings and
the Packers and the Vikings are beating
them and I think to myself huh I got a
shot that's what I actually thought I
was I'm superstitious I go this good
it's good and every commercial there
they are the Vikings and they're beating
them and I guess beat them and then
Jimmy opened with a Louie joke he said
who would have thought that Louie
Anderson
was my new favorite television mom right
right that's another good thing yeah -
for - looking for - so then I'm the
first award yeah it's the first award
the Supporting Actress yeah and so he
they read it and the cameras all go on
you and one walked up on me you know
from the aisle and I go hmm that's not a
bad [ __ ] Ammerman no well they're all
on everybody on okay but I didn't you
know I didn't I fellow no can you hear
Louie and you hear Louie Anderson what's
a girl on black issues so great oh yeah
yeah
David did Diana Ross's daughter right is
that you the main actress on that no I
don't know that either
yes I can't remember a first name now
but it's something something wrong Diana
is a second yeah when rain the mountain
oh yeah and they read my name and I went
yes I was happy
yeah and you know that is thing you want
to do haha everybody know from Simpsons
who's the guy who does Nelson want to do
that to everybody but you don't and I
was I was thrilled because I bet out
some formidable actors what are you
thinking as you walk up Sloane fall
don't fall fall so honestly I ll do you
know I'm 63 I'm you know six to seven
hundred pounds and so I'm a lot like 170
pounds right did it hurt thank you for
you but you know what I mean young big I
gotta get up those stairs that's all I'm
thinking honestly and then I'm going
come on you on you on you won you won
you won you won you won you won you won
you won and how much better is it for
this to happen now then like early on
you know what I mean it's good always it
is I don't you know I you're right I
mean is it good cuz I'm 63 uh-huh you
know what I mean
no I don't think I don't think you think
it's better now people say that it
graded the Twilight you you shut up
I don't beat that [ __ ] out of you shout
out Granite Twilight a year year your
twinkle head I think these wanted an
absolute yes I do not want them assuming
anything right well I wouldn't go that I
liked it yeah that's ridiculous and cuz
people would know what they'd be asking
me but what do you mean by doing is good
no it's not yeah yeah yeah where are
they say oh how many was it to get this
here at the end of your career yeah all
of Austria Han you but they I really do
hate that that inference that how about
getting the role of a lifetime is it I
haven't played a man yet but no it is
wonderful and let people say whatever
they want because they're gonna let them
do that
stuff and say all those things and try
to be nice to them but it is wonderful
at the time and you know and it's always
a shot to win so I'm the project kid
right i won yeah I did blow the thing is
sure they taking that back after there's
no linear process like there's no that
is the right way to do it because you
have guys that women are 25 and then
here you go you when you do just no way
to look at it and go okay that's the way
to all the citizens truism
yeah there's no linear and you know we
we were really careful about how we
played that I mean I I was really like
conscious of don't be cartoony with this
yeah who's who's treated with it did you
go in and decide I'm not going to change
my voice I'm just going to be exact to
the director Jonathan kreisel who you
know who he is pearl and Ian yeah yeah I
know he's Magothy I know right yeah do
you know John yeah I know I guess when
he know he's a dill delightful him and I
go I get there I'm shooting the pilot
under secrecy you know louis c.k budget
yes nobody can know anything yeah and I
go I walk up to Jonathan I'm in full
drag no which is weird because I never
cared to dress in women's clothes I'd
tell you who I did I wouldn't be ashamed
of them wouldn't blame you I've done it
it's okay yeah
and I said John I'm not going to change
my voice he goes yeah don't just like
that that was all you so I'm so great
about it because I watch Tambor play
transparent yeah it even changed himself
all right I mean he changed himself but
he didn't change himself he was and I
went I'm not going to change myself
either because I think it could have
been hey your everybody hi is your
mother
no I said no I said I'm just going to be
I'm just going to do I'm gonna make
Louie Anderson disappear in this part
that's my goal every show and it was so
funny the thing that you I think you
talked to us about it or Zach you talked
about it with the gulp of water that you
almost choked on and you can have
refreshing them but I know when right
and it was really yeah I was gonna try
and chug it I hadn't dropped anything to
the 70 anyway I haven't you know how you
think it can do that when you're young
you can drink a whole bottle of sure
muscatel and I'm using such old revered
musket you know what muscatel is yeah I
don't know you do alright alright well
some acknowledge I could get it here it
is right here this is what it was that
and so I think I'm going to be able to
do it and right here one two he goes to
three and he's laughing you could be
exact so was it a bagless vacuum as long
as where's what they left that yeah I
guess you know that is okay look sighs
he's biting the glass and oh that hit BA
finally that hit the spot and that was
the most you know like a you know so in
a sense yes I am 63 so I get why people
would ask that question because you're
63 to get that part in the minute now if
I win it next year then they they can't
ask that question no no I can't yeah
you're 64 now right I think you could go
63 and 64 this is why sports people
mad at the reporters you just won the
champion the repeat Monday's yeah shut
up I will put a bag over your head let
me have my victory what did you do that
night after you won laid down just like
a tired yeah no I went to uh cover me
with petals oh I went to mr. chalice
right okay you know mr. Chong yes I've
tried in Beverly Hills if you're gonna
go somewhere yeah very old Hollywood we
go with Abraham my you know personal
best greatest I thank him and the thing
is the greatest wear business partner a
few shows together and he is somebody
who I just love and he's the guy always
says to me you're you're a mess you know
one of those people is honest with you
sure yeah it's his birthday happy
birthday wait gay bro so he's got it
he's a guy who will tell you what you
really need to hear even if you don't
want to hear it because he cares about
you but do you like that when people do
it if they do it a certain way I do if
it's funky about it but if someone's
telling me something that's genuine yeah
I mean I should I do but what if they're
kunti about it I've been annoys me yeah
because it but he's not but if he was it
will annoy me if I think somebody is
secretly being aggressive about it this
is a way to tell somebody something
cause like look man I hate you gotta fix
this or someone just being counting on
hey stupid yeah no no no no and I do it
under the guise of love and care all of
you know people I really look at almost
my managers out there because you don't
let him in the room and know you can
hear he's really a great guy and he's
the same way he'll tell me stuff you
know because people care about me you
know I am a addict you know I'm a food
addict and so you know people go so you
eat a lot yeah yeah you eat a lot when
your food at you don't get 400 pounds
you don't just write you know just like
drugs you have to work at drugs drugs
food is different but it's the same yeah
it's not much it's not very much the
sorting section very similar we ask food
and set
both messy and you got to wipe your face
[Music]
anyway yeah so you want that in life you
want some people you want confidants
that will just tell you hey man you are
you got to watch it you got to take care
of yourself you got to do this you got
to do that yeah so it's a really great
ride this is a great ride few people
coming out of the Woodworks now this is
sort of this is a success and you're a
success story of it and and and all that
let's see I was just getting my photos
can't get enough good photos Kenya no
I'm leaving it one you know I guess to
you for it's 20 out of the woodwork yeah
you know there's those people you just
don't aren't going to contact right that
contact you but for the most part I'm
grateful I think for the most part
people just want to know that you
remember that they are there they don't
really necessarily right and they just
want to be acknowledged people want to
be acknowledged that's why people you
know you know because we because we
minimalize people and we marginalize
people these are the people that are
blown themselves up these are the people
that you know people who are you know
you know when you talk about a serious
subject you you what affects you more
than being blown off in a situation like
let's say you walked in here and you
were a pretty good comic and we all blew
that person off that would be about as
hurtful as it could get yeah it builds a
lot of resentment yeah and that
resentment is you know that's that's
trouble yes Emma will crush a person and
so um you know I think it's important
that we I try to be nice to everybody I
really go by my mom's thing I really go
she said you never know what kind of day
people had you should be nice to him
have you had to go back and make amends
to anybody like oh yeah I'm trying to
show you that yes and yeah yeah yeah
lots of people anybody who is an addict
I think the attic behavior lends itself
to you go listen either you know there
was a I was in my food frenzy and when
you can see when you're in one of those
what is it I don't know what a food
frenzy Jeff you know it isn't like that
as much you know like I don't have that
you know like but the thing is it's not
just about the food right it's about the
behavior so you could be on drugs you
could be on food you could be an alcohol
and you are you know your ego is now in
control of your being that at the
addiction the ego I think feeds that and
so your your your dismissive your
arrogant you know all those things and I
try to really work on that like I work
really hard now every day I start my day
in prison meditation which is really
hard because my brain is going and that
explain I think is going immediately you
get up you go alright yeah and so what I
try to do is quiet that mind do my
prayers read a prayer book or two and
and I Center my so I give myself over to
a higher being in this case God and I
say hey help me get through today and
help me you know be in your presence and
help me not be so anxious to get things
going and let me let you show me some
correction and some purpose most of the
craziness to comes from just being
afraid like I'm afraid I'm going to fail
I'm afraid of being a relative afraid of
all this stuff and it's like all this
anger and rage erupt it builds up it's
just pure basic [ __ ] all fear its
whatever isn't love is fear right I mean
you can you but can you grasp that cuz I
feel real hard one to grasp you know
whatever isn't love is a sphere right
you know like will like like I was
thinking about I was on the Kelley show
before I came here and I go I want that
job next to Kelly sure you know but I'm
63
sure and I'm you know four hundred poems
so they're not yeah that is it they
aren't quite uh let's keep Louie in the
running you know drama dollars fever you
know what I mean I'm never in the
running for that so I had to say to
myself well you know Lou you're not in
the running for that and it's because of
you you're not in the running if you
lost 100 pounds
and one two more Awards no if you run
for more award and you would have to
lose the weight so if you just no but I
mean you have to be responsible for what
you're in the running for you know and
so this part came out of you know some
sort of magical place this part didn't
this part wasn't like a casting choice
right this was just a sack and Louie
saying is that couldn't they couldn't
find the person they wanted and he said
- Zach what does it sound like and Zach
made a noise and Louie said you mean
like Louie andis that sounds like Louie
Anderson he goes yeah I guess that you
know this is the story I get any cuz
should we call them then they called me
I mean I always think I think that's
kind if you don't know if you believe or
not I believe in that kind of stuff my
mom it's you nudge somebody that Louis
mom knew or so you know I just believe
in that I want to believe I want to
believe because you know it'll it'll
it's more it's more comforting to
believe yeah we have to wrap up I hate
wrapping up the show is over we're gonna
hire your show is oh yeah why you know I
love you guys we only want to come back
earlier next time going to your TV but I
want to come be come early so we like
yeah yeah yeah you know I have I get
more comments about the show and the
stories I tell and and is everybody out
there who is really lonely and suffering
and not sure yourself just hang in there
hang in there great that's exactly the
opposite message that we normally give
that's very encouraged
Willie Anderson the great Louie Anderson
who I love very much season two of
baskets premieres Thursday at 10 p.m. on
FSC Emmy award-winning Louie Anders have
granite and well-deserved they don't so
much thanks for all the support here you
guys coming for graduations buddy and I
will see you guys tomorrow